the NSA is building right now
a I believe it costs 1.7 billion dollar
facility in Bluffdale Utah which is 25
miles away from Salt Lake City that's
gonna hose hose it's gonna house a
hundred thousand square foot data center
where they're going to be monitoring us
there it is it looks very much like a
moon base or something from Star Wars
those what what you're seeing right
there are just the cooling things to
keep the computer is cool because they
are sucking that much data and data is
hot I guess and do you mind that your
tax money is going to this type of thing
to report and record and watch you at
all times well I'm kind of glad they put
it in Utah to really monitor our natural
resources like Mormons and salt water so
that's really good that they did it
there yeah but I actually I don't mind
even when the Bush administration was
sort of watching us yeah I I think going
back to the Fox News thing I think the
people who are being monitored aren't
Fox News Watchers there are people who
are calling internationally I know it's
it's not it's not ideal but I feel like
if they can stop another attack I think
to me I feel a little safer but even
though that now they're saying that it's
not just international calls now that
they're they have the metadata for all
of us that doesn't and then keywords and
all that so that doesn't bother you why
no I'm really interesting so I'm just
glad I can provide phone call I need
someone else to be listening to me
deeper for that the nation just saying
anywhere you can have any conversation
just a minute another TV credit I want
to be taken into some jail take another
Guantanamo yes now I said slight sarcasm
there but you and I mean what do you
think like we're building giant
facilities there's no oversight the
government's just pouring money into all
this stuff it's right first of all I'm
like it's one of those things like we've
arrived in the future and it's freaking
scary like you know it's it's kind of
terrifying even to look at the facility
to look
where your thing like the cooling stuff
just for all that data that they're
processing the fact that they need an
entire section just to cool down house
off of ours that they're going through
it's really terrifying and I understand
the people are saying what if it saves
lives what if it prevents another 911
but it terrifies me that there's really
it's kind of the Wild Wild West on this
they haven't really said this is how
we're gonna do it this is the only
people we're gonna listen to I mean it
then you can't profile people it's too
confusing I just don't understand how
you can have the right to just say hey
we're the government elected by you but
now we're gonna spy on you even though
most people if you ask them and I think
your opinions interesting is you know
some people are like if it keeps us
safer that's fine most people are like
hello I don't want you spying on me and
I don't believe in that well if you're
doing nothing wrong then it shouldn't
matter because so why like why should
they have access to everything you do on
the internet and your phone just because
they're the government that's right I'm
scary I actually think that's the
weakest argument against it because the
look and you could be doing nothing
wrong and just sending emails work
emails where you say something mean
about someone you work with which is
perfectly legal or you could be watching
porn that's perfectly legal but you
don't want the government to be like oh
well we know now know this about you and
we're gonna tell all your friends no
much porn you watch well they can be
made against you in other arenas it's
kind of just like how basic traffic
stops work out just like in basic just
law enforcement cops will you know if
they decide they want to pull somebody
over they'll look for the slightest
little thing in order to get in to try
to get somebody for something else
and they're saying what that person was
doing something wrong like a taillight
is out or they weaved one so maybe they
can be pulled over on suspicion of drunk
driving but ever the person sober
they're still kind of being harassed
because they want to racially profile or
they wanted to for some reason pull a
person over so they're looking for the
smallest thing I think that every slope
that happens when they start listening
to your conversations and monitoring
your emails yeah isn't the other
problems oh that you know Obama keeps
saying well you know or everyone keep
saying that but this isn't all getting
up to Obama it's dealt with in mid-level
whatever so but isn't that where all the
abuse is gonna take place like the SIA
the Cincinnati IRS guys you know like I
don't believe Obama was you know the
lunch table in the Cincinnati IRS office
going let's do this but like it never
gets up to the highest
yeah yeah you could arguably can be like
okay well my sister's having a problem
with her you know ex-husband
so let's target him and look for some
keywords and haul him in like it's just
I'm gonna know who's overseeing it and
what control they have and what power
they have because you mean sort of
hauling people in for all sorts of
reasons for saying things just based on
this you know there's like patriarchy on
wild basically right so as the guy that
wants safety since you want safety more
than privacy do do you think that we can
trust the gatekeepers who are the
gatekeepers that's the problem think
about how much data they're collecting
and then how many analysts are gonna go
look for my new show that has nothing
like you're not gonna find if Steve my
brother-in-law is cheating on my sister
I don't think I can't call it hey
Michael at the NSA can you just do quick
favor warming and you see if Steve is
cheating on my sister at the NSA and you
decide to abuse that power or use it to
get people in trouble for other things
like I didn't mean it like oh I'm pissed
off but somebody's I'm gonna call my
hookup at the NSA I mean like get on
them start monitoring them but if you
work they working like your tone
Cincinnati you can you can start to
abuse things if your mid-level it's like
obviously if you're so high-profile you
can't really abuse or else it's obvious
but if you're just working there you can
kind of remember you want so for example
this guy Edward Snowden who released all
these documents to the Guardian he's a
mid-level contractor this guy doesn't
even have the highest levels of access
and he still was able to release all
doesn't that thing look like it looks
yeah it looks like something out of a
sci-fi movie where either neo or Tom
Cruise or Will Smith would have to go in
and destroy that look like the enemy it
does exactly what you're saying though
it does well it's like so postmodern now
that we have exactly the thing that in
every movie we've been told is the evil
empire that they have to go break into
to protect us all from the government
that's all why that guys one more time
with the air conditioning thing I I'm
picturing like Luke Skywalker flying in
on an x-wing and he has to shoot right
into a little hole to blow up the really
good solution I think what the NSA has
to do is remove all the people that work
there who wear eye patches because
they're the ones that are going to cause
the trouble
Oh generally they're untrustworthy the
eye patch people and solving America's
problems here yeah yeah and and I don't
care they can listen to my phone call
yeah all of you with eyepatch ease feel
free to comment about Sean Holub I know
there's a lot of eye patches